Counter-Strike 2 Is Real at least that
is the very well substantiated rumor on
the street the question is
what is it is it a fully fledged sequel
is it an update will it have 128 take
better matchmaking will your skins be
okay the real answer is
I have absolutely no idea but that has
never stopped us from speculating before
and we're here so
let's speculate away
[Music]
okay so before we get into CS2 or Source
2 or whatever let's talk about merch
head over to shop.thescore.com to check
out our Esports collection we've got
t-shirts hoodies and Crews and several
designs and colorways I know I work here
but I really do wear them all the time
they're awesome all right so for
everybody wondering why this week's
source to hysteria is particularly
pronounced it all started about a week
ago when an Nvidia driver referencing CS
go S2 and CS2 caught data miners
attention driving the community into a
frenzy now for those who are in the csgo
community you know that this is very
very standard stuff Source 2 has been
coming to CS go for eons and
there's already parts of it in CS go but
still every few months the rumor mill
churns up another Surefire guarantee
that we're getting the full transition
within the month week or
there's basically an entire
entertainment industry built around it
but I think it's fair to say that this
one feels
different what really tipped the scales
wasn't the official CS go Twitter
account cheekily changing its Banner but
a report by Richard Lewis claiming the
Counter-Strike 2 is not only real but
arriving very shortly like sometime in
the next month so what does
Counter-Strike 2 mean is it merely the
long-awaited source to update or a fully
fledged sequel to the game
well I don't know no one knows that's
the thing but we can and will speculate
it seems likely for instance that we're
probably not staring down the barrel of
an entirely separate game that will
exist independently from CS go the way
that's Source did from 1.6 the reason
for that is sort of simple it's not
really what Counter-Strike needs right
now CS go is fine it's actually more
than fine literally more people are
playing the game right now than ever
before and for valve to willfully
fracture the player base like that would
be nonsensical plus then they'd have to
maintain two cs's and I mean
they barely maintain one as his it's
also just not the way that esport
multiplayer titles are maintained and
sustained in the Modern Age League DOTA
OverWatch Siege valorent these games
don't really have sequels per se they're
just updated in perpetuity speaking of
DOTA that's pretty much the closest
analog to what is likely to happen to CS
back in 2015 valve poured a Dota 2 over
to Source 2 in one Fell Swoop the update
was dubbed Dota 2 reborn and it
modernized the game's entire physics
engine making it look and feel crispier
than ever before the reason it took
seven years for valve to do that with cs
go is
complicated Counter-Strike is Infamous
for having so-called spaghetti code
since the engine is older and more
convoluted than pretty much any other in
existence at least that is what a former
valve developer has elucidated several
times on social media so while I have
zero understanding of like the actual
Nuance of all of this I was around for
before and after Dota 2 reborn and I can
attest to the fact that it did make the
game look feel and run much much
smoother that said a lot of the benefits
that Source 2 promises to bring might
not be discernible to the average player
back end stuff that'll make
Counter-Strike easier to update fix
Implement stuff into help with mapping
stuff like that could be huge for the
game long term if there was a new engine
and if it actually is coming more people
can potentially work on it more features
could be added things could be changed a
lot easier
and you know for some lore
valve didn't make the original CS like
game or anything so like all this like
from the from the ground up like they're
dealing with somebody else whenever they
make changes to the game as for when
it'll happen Lewis's report claims that
valve has already flown Pros out to
their Seattle office in secret to test
it out and that it will be ready to
enter beta sometime before the end of
the month at that point we're likely to
see Counter-Strike two or whatever they
end up calling it become the de facto
build for both casual and competitive
play
but again it's Val so who knows the
report also claims that included in this
update will be I can't believe I'm
actually saying this
128 tick servers and a better
matchmaking infrastructure this means
that you'll no longer have silver threes
in your Global lobbies and that you'll
actually be able to throw all of that
utility that you spent hours learning
without having to hop into a Facebook
server
this is huge man it should have happened
years ago but hey
better late than never speaking of face
it I see a lot of people out there
saying that third-party services should
be sweating bullets right now and while
I can't predict the future I'm not so
sure
um valve's anti-cheat is still dog water
and I peeing a hell of a lot better to
face it servers than I do to the
official matchmaking ones but then again
the new servers might be better who
knows but the biggest question on
everybody's mind is undoubtedly one of
the reasons why this update took so long
in the first place what happens to
everybody's skins well they Port over or
get left behind do I sell my knife now
or do I wait and see do I start buying
as many skins as I can is it a fire sale
help
the homie zipple put it best so be sure
to check out his recent Twitter thread
for the full answer but the gist of it
is this for better and For Worse Skins
are the most important thing in
Counter-Strike period for valve to just
abandon the economy that they spend
literally a decade building would just
like to be clear it would be Financial
suicide it wouldn't even be worth the
update like if you told me hey there's a
new Counter-Strike uh it plays better
it's shinier the textures are cooler but
you don't get to bring your inventory
with you I would just keep playing the
old Counter-Strike and I'm pretty sure a
lot of the community would I would never
go so far as to say that CS go would be
nothing without skins because I think
that's an overstatement but it sure is
wouldn't be what it is today what the
migration looks like is anybody's guess
but it's safe to assume that valve have
solved it or at least the bulk of it or
else they wouldn't be pushing Source 2
in the first place the game is
continuing to reach unprecedented player
numbers and there is zero reason to
think that valve would just up and
tamper with the one thing that makes
them the player base and the Esports
infrastructure a shitload of money
what's infinitely more likely is that
your knives will Port over look even
shinier attractive even more players and
go up in value even more now I'm not a
soothsayer and I don't pretend to be but
that is in my opinion a lot of people's
opinion the most reasoned take about
what is gonna happen so to summarize
this week's speculation Which is far
from unfounded a fully fledged
Counter-Strike sequel with new guns Maps
animations Allah Counter-Strike source
is unlikely I think
source to I.E a game engine update to
the existing Counter-Strike
infrastructure
probably very likely happening very very
soon with it comes innumerable
performance upgrades the vast majority
of which you and I do not understand
128x servers better matchmaking and most
importantly yes your Skins are very
likely gonna be just fine anyway that's
all I got for you today
fingers crossed that this too isn't a
giant bait and switch
long have we waited for Source 2 my
friends and it finally finally feels as
if the time has come to rejoice
it's just like it's not I said in the
piece like I would never go so far say
the Cs go would be nothing without skin
because that's not true like it is the
crispiest
you know most strategic most addicting
shooter like it just is just the best
but like you know the game is really
good but it's not like
I'm gonna get spit roasted for saying
this but like it's not that you know
what I mean like it's really good and I
would still play it more than I would
play anything else yeah